miss dolly parton and e.t has spent
decades with dolly
all the way up to her big all-star
tribute
[Music]
this is a big deal to me huge and i am
very honored and very proud and i'm just
dying to
hear all these wonderful singers seeing
my music
you've all been dolly fans forever she
is incredible she's
funny she's talented in every avenue
i love her so much she doesn't really
let me call her a godmother she likes
fairy godmother much better
i love one of these things that she said
which was people ask me why my feet are
so small and i say things don't grow in
the shade
she just makes me feel really brave
because she is
still to this day such a powerful voice
so that's the effect she's had on me i
named my baby after her
so she's pretty special to us yep that's
the kind of love that queen of country
gets we were there in 2019 when she was
honored as person of the year
now the never before seen event drops on
netflix dolly parton
a music here's tribute features
performances of her classic songs by the
likes of katy perry
miley cyrus and shawn mendes
but we've known dolly a long time four
decades to be exact
we've seen her transform from singer
songwriter
to actress and producer we were with her
on her earliest movie sets
including rhinestone with sylvester
stallone
this is so nuts it's got to be love as
far as my acting i don't consider myself
a great actress
e.t was along for the ride as dolly
created her estimated
600 million dollar empire starting with
her dollywood theme park in 1986
her own cosmetics line and even opening
her own restaurant
i dress like dolly parton tonight
from the sets of our music videos to
insider closet
to being with her for her beloved
christmas projects all the way to
vaccine maker vaccine vaccine vaccine
vaccine
we've been with dolly every step of the
way but i do love to work
and i'm thankful every day that god lets
me do what i love to do